hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within I'm
still rolling from the last recording
and I'm ready to get more into this game
because it interests me and I'm
competent enough to keep going on it
which is good enough for me I am not
doing so terribly that I'm dying over
and over oh oh oh oh this back after the
ambulance fell into the river or the
ravine or whoever lusts nurse oh hello
dr. earners
I appreciate the tender moment to hold
hands oh that don't look good
I saw that I did you see that did you
guys see that what changed in between a
woman and it might have been hard they'd
do something to my head ensure you don't
move well you should take better care of
yourself
Oh should I now well then I have not
been good on finding matte pieces I
don't know if I'm like way far away from
playing this game but no idea Church
floor collapses no injuries witnesses
saves says miracle biggest Church
scandal to date floor of Cedar Hill
Church collapses during renovations
parishioner says it was a miracle no one
was injured so why is it the biggest
Church scandal the floor collapsed I
have no idea okay what do we got on the
desk here okay that's the Lighthouse
Church I think did someone just walk
into warm the door just opened who's
that no baby the church that's the floor
collapsing is that the one during the
renovations is there someone in this
room with me
[Music]
okay okay so yeah why do I do
oh okay I was here the whole time I just
had to turn on my flashlight oh this bad
isn't it no that looks awfully like the
box that I saw on a certain enemy at the
preview trailers of this game or
whatever on box art and whatnot so oh
wait no didn't I see a combination with
the dial of the top and the bottom I did
that to release on Nicole Kidman that
means that how's the sound of a
wheelchair thank you very much
you're not very observant are you mr.
detective kind of police work did you do
crappy police work oh good just brain in
a jar whoa 5,000 brain in a jar I forgot
the brain in the jar and those things
are really good all right does someone
want the sweet taste of a shotgun this
is a tasty tree that can't be be please
ignore the pubic bear tic crack in my
voice so I can't save so something bad
is going on can I upgrade my brain hole
is that a thing I could do I'm gonna
find out another room in there there's
someone in there then I need to know
about em let me just do this first
oh let's just someone over here someone
anyone why am i volunteer why is that
similary er what is with the symbols the
symbols to be something has got to be a
clue that I could piece together in this
what is that chemical in there
what are you injecting into my face okay
so I can upgrade the damage again which
is something I want to do please yes
okay that'll do for now going on in this
locale oh by the way if you guys didn't
connect the dots in that other room a
few episodes back er a couple episodes
we saw a diagram of that very machine
now I don't know if this is all by the
same guy roof occur if there's more than
one person in the cahoots in the cahoots
with all this I have a feeling that
doctor whose brother is in the hospice
place isn't telling me wool
I didn't think this would open I
honestly didn't always this my Nosa my
room I don't remember now it's been so
long since I tried so those bugs going
up that wall just I can't even touch
good god don't do that lady scare them
poopy out of me what you doing you vain
lady oh no you do not God the field of
view is so wonky in this one it's too
close I can't see it uh who's over there
who's doing one now come in my room so I
Baron oh close this back off it seemed
like the walls of my room might have
turned into blood what about Leslie's
room okay I'll just carry on my wayward
son there'll be peace when I am done so
kick her that way so she went this way I
guess this is just follow where she went
oh I didn't even know there are stairs
here I can't see it's all much too close
oh well someone upstairs is angry you
know who's doing that okay what is
happening in my life what is going on
meister least we went to color no idea
these doors are not opening well I'm
just gonna check just to make sure I'm
not missing anything
Leslie tell you again causing nightmares
again I know you're in cahoots with
Ravich I saw you in your little buddy
buddy session this way that's like I'm
so calm and collected
that's like madly
hey Leslie Leslie Sebastian that's me
Russian see pistachio Bastian
Wowz insane crazy I love it good lord it
loo okay where am I now
good am i outside yet my outside my own
mind
please tell me that's an agony bolt
thing harpoon gun please please oh yes
finally oh I've been waiting for this
all my life all my life oh I've wanted
this so badly I have so many bolts I
have so many bolts maybe it was like a
bug in the game because I know I got
bolts when I was uh I preordered uh my
um my voice is cracking all over the
place I know had bolts when I preordered
it I know yes I I know okay so hold ctrl
to make a boat hard to change bolt have
you so many balls and so many bolts and
bready oh god yes so many bolts I'm
gonna make all the bolts cuz I just got
so many crafting parts I'm full of every
bolt even the one with a little brain on
a stick I love it
love it okay so I don't have any more
grenades so that's not gonna help me out
in the anyway how do I change my bolt I
don't know what button that is it's just
a circle thingy oh it is are just does
that okay I got it so and I bet I hold
down our to replace the bolt if I have
one in there already
let's try since I like it so much I'm
gonna try the poison bolt
I like the idea of shooting a little
anybody brain at people cuz I'm weird
like that so don't judge me don't you
don't know me I don't know anybody this
looks nice seems to be back in the area
where we were when we started this game
and the bit of a village there that
looks their releases the crew depress
yeah same place it's not a church or
what it's not supposed to be I how did I
get farther away from the lighthouse
thing and let's say was supposed to I
have no idea
I'm not I have no idea about anything in
this game so I'm just gonna keep going
forward at least it's daytime nice and
luminescent so that I don't have to
worry about something sneaking up on me
everything wants to sneak up there gonna
be something at the top of this tower no
piece of a map maybe get some brain
juice okay so I can make a leap over
there
there we go okay never mind I was just
pretending there we go come on there had
to be something else up there maybe out
the window there was a way to go let's
go be something here they wouldn't have
this if there was nothing this boxes
there that look like they're supposed to
be traversed no okay nevermind one more
trap whoa whoa where you going buddy
detective Sebastian Castellanos all
right never mind that ain't possible if
that is possible I don't have the
patience to try it because I got a time
schedule to keep and I gotta kill some
zombies if there are any zombo's left to
kill I'm gonna kill her so oh that is
ombo that needs killin I could kill him
right now light him up like the fourth
of July
that's that oh gosh you're right Oh key
I know that was gonna be a key there and
a grenade thank you sir
are you the key puppet are you through
the key pinata
give me more please thank you when I
stay sir
could there be a point to climbing out
of there okay okay enough exploring the
environment I gotta keep moving forward
uh-uh don't don't don't take a breather
goddammit if you took a breather right
there whoa hello
who's shooting new I'm shooting at me
someone I got a crossbow dying to use it
you don't want a little brain on your
face that would stink or something I
don't know it'd be not pleasant
just in general huh Joe Joe Joe Joe are
you feeling okay Joe Joe are you all
right
Am I my head would stop buzzing it felt
like it was about to crack open but now
it's like
I'm starting to get used to it started
used to water you seen Kidman no next
thing I knew I was here I must have
blacked out
maybe I turned again baby what did you
do to declare oh there are the zombo's
so they've had to turn into night inside
let's go okay yay the dual buddies are
back again burger man Jensen oh that's a
massive cocktail why should I love you
oh that's not mine no you another one
you carefully disarm that
[Music]
well they're gonna look into fire right
now so I don't have benefit they're
gonna get from that you look pretty or
something couple that's fabulous comfort
working on it just give me a little time
the whole place is on fire I can't
really give you any more we already have
time to come over there so you get up in
your leisure I'm gonna just add more
fire yeah walk close to that I don't
care about the Flies ball
we're just go
[Music]
whoa out of ammo here we go run slow
time just keep me covered
I got you covered I got everyone coming
whoa okay I'm officially out of mana
does
that's bad I wanna kill you women
trouble dude this prosper not as good as
it was advertised to be oh come on
that's creepy
that is creepy I will admit that's Oh
that almost felt good
I'm on fire in death I'm dead I'm dead
okay not dead you don't know
there was stuff over here the whole time
this horrible dude so badly
I'm trying to keep you covered but hey
you alright expectations realistic
thanks for asking
yes last of all Dino perfect I'm okay
but everything is awesome everything
miss every shot
Oh drama cross Oh drama queue oh it's a
priest
[Music]
oh my life that was like the last one
god damn the son of a [ __ ] this
crossbow I thought it was going to be
fantastic but it just caused me pain and
suffering
okay some of these people need more than
no more than one to persuade him into
death this is pretend like an ambulance
whoa I'm on the backdrop much longer
another moment just keep me covered
yeah I can I'm fine okay so I got this
now Axew
okay chocolate time burn you up burn you
down bro
hello sir nothing yet Myrna
fine fine
having seen the old in BBC
thank you now I need to use some of
these all right come on the way sir
thanks for being such a good sport oh
there's more to do another one well
we're gonna have a lot of fun
what do you want you want a second
I've lots of that we can
you fall down fall down you give her
need to reload
fern you know how much I have left in
terms of matches
most animals time uses what our it will
do
but that's good
[Music]
but okay okay we love this we love Rilla
Rilla
come
I mean
Oh fire fire fire
Oh God why did I get trapped there
nothing else gonna be
[Music]
is that the sound of a door opening
better than the sound of a door opening
let's go let's go let's go
[Music]
incredibly challenging I don't know why
Oh God
we can't keep going at this pace you're
no kidding cuz of all he was doing to
help out of this place as fast as we can
yeah what about the tower there we might
be able to get a lay of the land sure
better than staying here man that was
that was really tiny it's it's like the
selection system on the uh I'll kill you
buddy cuz I can do that to you but you
can't do it to me terribly so I need to
use my Oh a sniper unit excuse me sorry
that's very rude you didn't tell me I
could get a sniper rifle how am I
supposed to get enough brain juice to
ever be able to upgrade all these things
you gotta be nuts you gotta be out of
your mind
I need these healthkit pick that one up
but I did be pretty good that last run
after I died oh wait are we having an
episode again why are you complaining
about your job should not be complaining
about mine good thing I got another key
where's the pyramid head clone Oh God
more brain juice yes I would love that
more brain juice thank you I need to
upgrade yes I know what is that what is
that oh that's a way out okay so each of
these rooms have a way out so I don't
have to go very far well isn't that just
convenient excuse me while I look over
your shoulder and say don't mind me
getting so close to you do you good
I think it's chapter title was losing
our grips on ourselves
losing grips on ourselves something like
that about losing yourself or something
alright whatever so I'm gonna look into
this because two new weapons in a row
like okay yeah I could have gone through
the whole game with a pistol on a
shotgun but now everything gets
interesting
so that thing charged time well that
would be useful because that's what
really got me in trouble
these are all pretty cheap upgrades so I
guess I might as well go for it
dot diet I let you reload time yes
Ollie's would be good I'm a sniper rifle
what have you got
IRA clip capacity man get have more
stock of things at least I'll have more
variety of ammunition to go through I
mean the sapper F will be good but
that's only as good as I can hit things
in the face of Matt damn I still haven't
done this syringe recovery here I mean
it doesn't do that much but I keep
forgetting about it in favor of other
things that you have done for me
whatever the hell you are doing
I literally only have these left I don't
know what the poison does but the
explosive seems like it would be a good
thing so long as I can maintain my
distance but let me crapped up some more
because I get a lot of crap tables
actually let me assign this to for now
just so I can have that I got me I'm
gonna wait until I fill up more on those
before I get those now I need to craft
so which the frizzy1 was very nice
especially for clothes cool oh that
costs 5 no wonder it's great alright
that one costs - I don't know what that
is but I'll get it
and the fire one also goes 5 so why is
the poison one cost - it had no effect
from what I saw now whatever alright
it's good enough for me I need to learn
it cuz it's a new system obviously I'm
not a customer I've just got the weapon
I just started I just started up playing
again so hold on and bear with me while
I get adjusted to a new system
well this seems bad but they do seem to
be a bit of oh oh damn it damn it damn
it damn it all the hell what are you
doing
flailing uselessly sorry I'm gonna climb
up here if any of you want to follow me
also maybe Jojo you could ask them a
question or two I'm gonna put the sun's
back guy cuz he's gonna be good sorry I
see you think I'm just gonna oh no no no
no get to cover they're shooting from
above I know situation like the worst
situation could possibly be
what do you mean I can't do that I'm
gonna have to use trap strategically
who's shooting
this guy doesn't even know what's up hi
who did I hear noise around there watch
someone streamline wattle no word my
friends go after they'd overloaded Joe
Joe Joe Joe Joe
Jonjo Wow I'm impressed I only had to
heal you like two blips there Bob Jojo
can take a beating so they only pop up
when they're firing my head hazard
see this bulletin judges so come on
Jojo can you get off the boats waiting
[ __ ]
your phone
Jojo I think I'm gonna fire you
might see dust
almost over I almost got this though I'm
having fun
even though there's a little bit of a
back-and-forth thing like I'm really
trying to just trigger them but hey it
is what it is complain too much
you have a new first date I don't need
any first oh you need first aid just
stop whining you're barely
I'm not coming to help you Jojo if you
win this game for me I will be so mad
where's wasn't all over there really
come on show your ugly face
thank you good night everybody
I was wrong there and I actually got to
the wrong place so that's my man No
oh you piece of [ __ ] doh you piece of
[ __ ] Joe I'm so mad at you Joe Joe
really okay you know what he's gone
goodbye
now we're gonna play this now out of
ammo
who cares gonna get more misprint belly
it's gonna be fine stand a chance if we
don't take out those other guns
Danny Daniel give us a [ __ ] why why
would she do with the thing
I need to I need to use this because
it's too stupid like that this thing
dammit with this knob
oh no no guys to do all of this over
again which means that I gotta
accumulate all the ammo it's took me
forever last time
first aid do you need some cuz shut up
go out like this I ain't gonna let
nothing happen to nobody
just get up please you're fine
[Music]
should be able to finish off so long as
I don't miss thank you Joe finally god
damn it Joe
I need help you need help shut up Joe
you're the bane of my existence Joe you
leave me to drink and forget about
Miriam but Myra who's her name
then you are
since last time Joe do not get in a bad
situation this
you're on your own I'm gonna fix this
do not fall off any cliff
just let me
Venice's can't open you son-of-a-bitch
there we go
goddamnit knocking uh curtain
Mark Zuckerberg hey how's it going -
he's chillaxing hand in the way of
getting to the tower now yeah exactly
because yeah whatever you know what Joe
I don't I don't want to hear don't want
to hear any of your excuses anymore
because I've had it up to here with you
if you could just Joe if you just you
can just take care of that lovely den
think okay I'm all out of time for this
episode
it ran long because Joe is a bit of a
douche nozzle so thank you all so much
for watching I'll continue this soon and
as always I will see you
[Music]
Wow that got me here holy hell I'm
awesome oh I got my deep voice in there